because something's up because all of
you are parents and I think one of the
those lots of issues when you're a
parent but one of the things I think is
that you don't want to feel responsible
for your children ending up in therapy
because is that a concern we wanna think
I better not do that because oh every
time you do anything that you think's
wrong you think that's it that's sixteen
years of therapy get over that one
incident that's happening I mean I once
said to my son when he was about four I
said you know why daddy where's this and
he said is it because you hate yourself
why are you being the therapist to look
where Eddy heard that where in terms of
lazy celebrity parenting you see would
have a genius thing that you've done
have you done with all your children who
just was the first one because like the
shame was two months I mean I used to
I've done a lot of audiobooks and I
loved to unlock fairy stories so
casually if I was really busy
I'd put my child to bed and then reach
over and put in a CD of me reading a
fairy story I'd press play and then just
back out the door until he was about
seven he thought every story started
with read by Stephen Mangan
[Applause]
[Music]